Readers, beware. The fifth episode
of "House of the Dragon" changes a
key detail from "Fire and Blood,"
and one character looks all the
more sinister for it. Spoilers for
both the book and the show ahead.
Divisive final season aside, it's pretty
obvious that Game of Thrones has become a
permanent staple in pop culture. Now, it
seems, every detail about the characters,
confrontations, and locations in author
George R. R. Martin's world has become
ingrained in viewers' brains. From the names of
the Targaryens' dragons to the banners of the
houses of Westeros, Martin's world won't soon
be forgotten by fans of the classic series .
Thankfully, these morsels of TV-related trivia
have become an enormous help with our return trip
to the Seven Kingdoms in House of the Dragon.
Fans might struggle after being thrown into a
world so far removed from the events of Game
of Thrones, but the world itself is thankfully
familiar enough to give them the lay of the
land. In the case of this week's episode,
though, one notable landmark made an appearance
— one that has a well-known history of its own.
House of the Dragon's fifth episode, "We Light
The Way," features the short-lived debut of Rhea
Royce , the estranged wife of Daemon Targaryen.
The unhappy couple is reunited under the king's
orders after King Viserys commands his
brother to return to the Eyrie following
a recent scandal. And the location of their
reunion that holds particular significance.
Those that are only familiar with the TV
adaptation of Game of Thrones will remember
that the first time the Vale appeared in the show
was when Catelyn Stark visited her sister Lysa
Tully in the show's first season. It's also where
the friendship of Bronn and Tyrion began after the
former fought in a trial by combat.
"You don't fight with honor."
"He did."
The location was notorious
for its impregnable castle, known as the Eyrie.
Marked by steep paths and high vantage points,
the fortress has a solid track record
of maintaining the home turf against the
enemy — that is, until Daemon wandered through
the land with nothing but a rock and an attitude.
Yes, in House of the Dragon, Daemon Targaryen
basically manages to infiltrate and kill the
Vale's only defender: his wife, Rhea
Royce. It's an impressive victory for
Daemon — and more than a little grisly — but
this scene also features a significant change
from George R. R. Martin's original work.
In Fire and Blood, the book from which the
show is adapted, Rhea meets a similar end, but
it's one that takes much longer. While she does
fall from her horse and crack her head on a
rock, she then lives for another nine days,
bedridden. When she eventually does get up, she
collapses an hour later, and finally succumbs to
her injuries. Notably, Daemon doesn't kill Rhea
in the book. In fact, he's off fighting a war,
many miles away, when it happens.
However, the show's version of events
adds another layer of deception and cunning to
Daemon's character. Here, Rhea is just another
piece to move to how he sees fit. By the end
of the episode, Daemon is already at work not
only in brushing off accusations regarding Rhea's
death, but also in making moves on Laena Velaryon,
daughter of Corlys. He's certainly
not killing time, that's for sure.